>>Good day, Geoff Cape here from Evergreen
in Toronto at the World
Economic Forum, looking to explore the subject
of environmental issues
and how climate change, Copenhagen affairs
have essentially failed in a
very substantial way.
I think the agenda going forward is to try
find a way to enable useful
governments, urban issues to be the core with
change.
Nation states have not found the will or the
-- the legal mechanisms to
effect change.
But use some penalties, and could use some
urban governments both up to
capacity to make quick decisions and to enable
and effect change on the
ground through huge populations in cities,
much more effectively, much
more efficiently.
And enable social change and behavioral change
of a community, citizens
far more effectively, so that the quick agenda
I think is to find a way
to bring best practices of governments, useful
governments together
around the climate change agenda.
Thank you.